okay
question number one pastor skeet
the concept of keeping the sabbath holy
is new to me
are there any principles in the bible
that tell us what we should or shouldn't
do
is it wrong to eat out on sabbath
there are a couple of verses that
concentrate some principles
in isaiah 58 verses
13 and 14. isaiah chapter 58
verses 13 and 14.
the bible says if thou turn away thy
foot from the sabbath
from doing thy pleasure on my holy day
and call the sabbath a delight
the holy of the lord honorable and shall
honor it
not doing thine own ways nor finding
thine own pleasures
nor speaking thine own words then shalt
thou
delight thyself in the lord and i will
cause thee to ride upon the high places
of the earth
and feed with the heritage of thy father
jacob for the mouth of the lord hath
spoken it
now if you look back at verse 13 god is
saying if you
regard the holiness of the sabbath by
not speaking your own words
on the sabbath day our conversation
should be different from that which we
talk about
the other six days because it is
a different day and i don't mean to
preach to sermons
but if you read genesis 1 31 the bible
says
and god saw everything that he had made
and behold
it was what very good now everything he
made from day one
to day six was very good but as good as
they were he did not do any such thing
on the seventh day there are some things
that are not necessarily bad they're
just not suited for the sabbath
are you listening to me they are
unsuitable
for the sabbath so if god decided not to
work as good as his work was
we must be very careful what we talk
about on sabbath
what we do not finding our own pleasures
not doing our own ways nor speaking our
own words
the sabbath to us must be honorable
and we must honor it that is what god
says
so some fundamental principles are to
keep in mind it is
absolutely different from all the other
six
two something holy means it is reserved
cut off and separate from everything
else for a purpose
entirely devoted to god and three
it occupies a place of high honor in
god's view
consequently it must occupy a place of
high honor in our view
you keep these things in mind
they will guide you as to what is
suitable for the sabbath and what is not
i do not eat out on sabbath because all
the distractions
having to pay the man ordering listening
to people in an environment i cannot
control
i do not do that